all right thank you very much it's great
to be here this is the first time I've
ever given a talk at PI data I'm excited
about this topic I hope you guys find it
interesting it's really really powerful
and python is a great tool to do these
sorts of analysis it's working so I put
together there's a little bit of code to
talk through an example it's because of
challenges with the Wi-Fi I wasn't able
to upload all the data at this point but
it'll it'll altom utley throw this up
there including the slides but right now
there is a jupiter notebook if you want
to follow along with a little bit more
code and instead of the pseudocode that
are in the slides the so I work for
Apollo agriculture and Apollo's goal is
really just to help smallholder farmers
increase their profits and we do this by
in order to do it at scale we need to
leverage a whole bunch of different
technologies and and geospatial data is
a core component of that and and so
that's really what I want to sort of
focus on today some of the examples of
how we use this so a big part of it is
we need to determine with whom to give a
loan for seed and fertilizer for these
customers and we want to try and
determine as efficiently as possible who
is most likely to pay and so we use for
credit scoring we can do things like
look at GPS or sorry satellite data to
look at their house and measure how far
their house is from a road for example
and extract these kinds of features that
then we can feed into a credit model the
other thing we can do is we can look at
fraud detection we have a lot of people
applying for our loans and sometimes
there's legitimate confusion but
sometimes multiple people will apply for
the same piece of land and so that's one
way that we can use GPS data for that
when we actually mark a field to make
sure we're not giving multiple loans for
the same piece of land the other thing
we can do is we can actually do a lot of
work to analyze the farms themselves we
send out people to walk around the
boundaries of a farm and then using that
combined with time series of satellite
imagery
we can measure things like historic
yields or at least estimates of historic
yields from the satellite data once we
know where their farms are located and
then finally in order to be as low touch
as possible in order to reach as many of
the customers as we want we send people
out though our field agents who have
smartphones and we want to send them to
the location of our farmers and since
we're in Kenya Kenny doesn't really have
much in the way of an address system
it's hard to know where people are and
so we use schools as a proxy for that
and so we use this the spatial data set
of school locations that comes from the
Kenyan government in order to then help
route our field agents and let them know
where they need to go in order to meet
the farmers so these are sort of some of
the examples that that we use for me I
didn't really use facial data until I
started working for Apollo agriculture
my primary goal in this talk is to try
and be the talk that I wish I had had
before I started doing this to give a
background of this no one will become an
expert on any of these things in a short
talk like this but hopefully give enough
background where you can at least start
googling what you need to know in order
to solve your exact problem I see right
okay so I think all these talks need to
have at least one webcomic so here's
mine and I think that sort of leads me
to the secondary goal of this talk the
thing about working with geospatial data
that's great is it's plentiful and cheap
and there's all sorts of different
datasets you can get the thing that's
hard is that when you're dealing with
that it's easy to sort of make spurious
and false conclusion Cluj ins as this
person nicely demonstrates for us and so
I want to try and give a little bit of
an understanding and tools of how to do
a little bit better than this because
when you've done well you can get
incredible value out of geospatial data
but when it's done poorly well not so
much so a bit of background you know
let's talk about what I actually mean
when we talk about geospatial data you
know really simply all it is is just
data that is referring to a specific
location on earth and that comes in two
different forms so there's vector data
and vector data are points so this is
something like you know if you take a
single GPS reading on your phone
that's you know the actual single point
location you get things like lines so if
you have look I'm like OpenStreetMap and
you get you know the actual location of
a street is defined via a line or you
can have things like polygon so when we
have our agents walk around the
perimeter of a field that turns into a
polygon that is a well-defined has it
has some area associated with it and
then there's raster data which really is
basically an image and these sort of
come in two different flavors this these
somatic raster images where the values
are discrete so this will be something
like a land-use map
that'll have you know this is a forest
this is farm land this is a city or you
can have continuous data well obviously
it's not truly continuous since it's an
image but but this will be something
like you know your satellite image where
you're looking at you know all the RGB
values that you can have so for vector
data like I said you know this is really
defining a region in space and then you
attach some properties to it and so you
can use something like a JSON format and
you're just sort of specifying very
concretely the coordinates of the
location and then you can add in these
properties there are things you know
anything you want you know names marker
sizes whatever you want to whatever you
want to put into that you can do the
type of data formats you'll see this is
where you know shapefile is you know if
you're coming from sort of the GIS
community that's where you run into but
there's you know sort of a wide range of
formats that you can see and the sorts
of data sources you get this is how you
know if you have like survey data from
governments or NGOs they'll often end up
as sort of vector data and here's some
libraries that you can use I'm going to
try and make these slides as useful
resource as possible so I fill them in
with a bunch of links but won't
necessarily talk through everything so
this particular data point that we have
is actually this approximate location of
where we are this is what I grabbed from
the website so maybe I'm off by a little
bit and so this is how you using geo
JSON IO which is a nice tool to look and
sort of explore your vector data you can
easily plot this point it's then taking
the properties that I defined here in
terms of specifying things like you know
the marker and then throwing it on top
of a satellite
here and then that satellite image is
exactly the next piece of data that we
have we talked about raster data as I
said it's basically an image I use scare
quotes here because when we talk about
images it's not necessarily RGB values
it's not necessarily just limited to the
optical wavelength so when you deal with
satellite imagery you'll often have lots
of data in the infrared and even even
lower as that provides more information
about things like water or vegetation so
this is one of my favorite
visualizations this is using the
infrared along with green in order to
figure out where vegetation is and this
is done because the way photosynthesis
works you want to plants want to absorb
the green light but but not the infrared
light since that just makes it hot but
there's an energetic enough to do
photosynthesis and so you can make these
really strong contrasts and so this
shows over over the years on average
where vegetation is across the content
of Africa and this is exactly the sorts
of things that we're interested in in
Apollo a great culture you know the data
formats for this are basically just your
typical image files and then you have
some metadata attached to it and and you
can get this you know we use lots of
satellite imagery you can also use
things like aerial photography and then
in some cases things like elevation are
actually just more efficient to
represent as raster data clickers in
here so it kind of implicit in this
discussion is is location and I think
it's really worth spending a little bit
of time to talk about location and how
we how we specify it you know really
anytime you're talking about it you
always need a coordinate reference
system that mean this is true whenever
you're talking about data that that's
spatially located and so here what I'm
kind of showing you this is an example
in you know in a data format about how
you're specifying location and this kind
of stuff you see all the time and it's
really confusing it can be really
intimidating and so I kind of want to
walk through just a little bit about
what we mean here and hopefully sort of
demystify this stuff and and the key
thing is that
because not all data are represented in
the same coordinate system you need to
pay attention to this in order to then
make comparisons across different data
sources so the main thing is that
there's this epsg which is like European
Petroleum something and they put
together this geotech parameter set and
that's a convenient shorthand that's
used to specify these and so this here
is epsg 43:26 is how people refer to it
and that's that's this specification
that's used for your GPS and so I think
like you know we're really used to GPS
data we're used to thinking about in
terms of lat lawn but I think it's it's
useful to recognize that like that is
just one coordinate system that's used
and it's not the only one and so the
reason for this is that the the earth is
you know I think I don't know what
people probably recognize from school
you learn that the earth isn't actually
a sphere but it's an ellipsoid that's
also not true right I mean this is a
really complex body that's actually
moving all the time you have an
earthquake and everything shifts and so
there's a series of way in which we
specify the shape of the earth and so in
order to specify lat lon you need to
come up with an approximation for the
shape of the earth and then on top of it
you know - normally you approximate this
as being something like an ellipsoid and
there are different ellipsoids that are
used throughout a good approximation for
the ellipsoid in north america is very
different than a good approximation in
Australia and so there are different
ellipsoids that are used and then on top
of it if you want to be really accurate
you need to recognize that there are
these lumps throughout there's
inconsistencies and gravitational forces
and so you can specify that in terms of
the geoid all these things get encoded
into something like epsg 40 through 26
and that's that's sort of what that
means and then the last piece of it is
on top of the shape of the earth we
actually do a bunch of very careful
surveys so I come from the US and in the
US you see these actual disks mounted if
you go on a hike you'll see them all
time in in stone that is well survey
points and these points
dense Network and those are the way in
which then you interpolate in order to
know where things are and so that gives
you sort of the shape of the earth the
location of the earth and then on top of
that you have you have projections and
so that's going from three dimensions to
two dimensions so data that's that's
sort of how you come up with these dense
networks I love this image this is the
careful surveying of the subcontinent of
India that happened in the 1800s I am
continuously blown away by the amount of
care and dedicated data that happened
and was collected in order to understand
the shape of the earth I think I'm doing
ok on time so I want to tell this really
amazing story these guys were out there
in like the 1800s measuring this and as
they got near the Himalaya as they knew
that as they were surveying you want to
have a plumb line going straight down
when you take your measurements but they
knew that the Himalayan mountains are
going to cause gravitation so their
plumb line is not going to go straight
to the Sun of the earth but actually be
slanted towards the Himalayan mountains
so they were taking account of that and
they do this whole big arc of series of
survey points and they were off by a
small amount and so they were so
confident in their data collection that
they say you know like our calculation
for how the mass of the Himalayas is
shifting plumb line must be wrong and
the only way they could come up with
that was to propose that mountains
actually have structure underneath the
earth so on top of not just seeing the
physical mounds that you can see but
there is inconsistencies in the dense of
the earth underneath a mountain range
and this is sort of like preliminary
data that started leading to theories of
plate tectonics and it just blows my
mind that this is what they're figuring
out just because of the care of their
data collection so the data that you use
do do vary across the earth like I said
the most common is epsg 4326
that's what you use for GPS if you're
out collecting your own data it will
almost always be in this format but then
once you start combining it with other
sources of data if you grab like
government survey data or anything like
this it'll typically not be in that data
format so in North America you'll see
nad83 people are really creative with
their names that's the North America
datum 83 meaning you have
originally in 1983 if you're in Europe
you'll see edy 50 European data that
started in 1950 these things get
continually updated as they both collect
more data and taking into account the
slow shifts in in the locations and and
the key thing just to recognize that if
you're looking at one point on the earth
and you're using a different data you'll
get a slightly different number of in
terms of lat lawn and so you need to
taken that into account and then the
other thing you have is you have
projections so I think you know
projections are great it's a lot of fun
to nerd out about them the key thing to
recognize is just that every projection
leads to some amount of distortion it's
not possible to take a three-dimensional
shape put it down into two dimensions
and not lead to a distortion and so when
you're dealing with this what you want
to do is you want to try and come up
with the projection that best matches
your use case and so you often might
care about things like area or the shape
or direction what you know different
projections are optimized for those use
cases so here are two different
projections a common way to think about
distortions is these circles are all the
exact same size and shape on earth but
then when you move into a projection
they change so in the top-left this is a
Mercator projection and here what
happens is we are preserving the shape
of a circle but we lose the size and so
as you get away you get these
distortions of size I think we're all
pretty familiar with this projection we
see it a lot and alternative projections
on the bottom and this projection the
shape gets incredibly distorted but the
actual size of these circles are the
same so if you want to do a calculation
about the area so when we're calculating
the area of field for example we want to
work in in a projection the way area is
conserved or at least minimally
distorted common projections you'll see
one of the really common ones is the web
Mercator if you deal with any sort of
app this is what you'll probably use
this is what all the web maps use of
you're using Google Bing open source
Open Street Map yeah all of these are
using web Mercator z-- I find it really
interesting that that actually Microsoft
has by far the best documentation I've
seen on this I'm assuming this because
they're trying to recruit people and
they need to do it with document
but you'll see this all the time another
really common one is the the Platt car a
and that's basically just moving lat
lawn to X Y and so if you see something
that's as a map and it's listed as epsp
4326 that's not technically a projection
but that's just taking the lat lawn
that's specified and and putting it onto
XY and this is really common if you have
global raster data this is actually the
format that we'll see in a little bit
when I talk about nightlights and that's
that's the format of this to other
really interesting ones the transverse
Mercator I use all the time because
that's what you see with satellite
imagery the nice thing about these is
it's basically the distortion is minimal
along a line of longitude and so that's
the path as a satellite is takes when
it's collecting imagery and so that's
why you use this UTM is a series of
transverse mercator that you'll see a
lot of that are basically I think
there's 32 of them that go around the
earth and those are a way of there's a
commonly using satellite imagery and
then finally you know here's a whole
series of equal equal area projections
that they use all the time if you
calculate an area okay so the last thing
I'll start saying is the last sort of
theory ish slide is that you know I hope
I didn't bore you too much about this
stuff I hope you know these things are
all very you know important to keep in
mind but ultimately you know what you
really end up doing practically speaking
is you end up doing lots of
transformations from one projection to
another I stole this graphic and it's
just hideous font from Paul Ball stats
book which is an excellent reference if
you guys need to dig more into some of
the technical details behind these
things but basically ultimately all
you're doing is you're going to be
moving from one projection to another
and when you do that you have to go
through the geographic projection
meaning the the full like three
dimensional and typically your software
will handle that for you the reason why
I want to show this is just to emphasize
that like just going from one projection
to another is come there's no distortion
in this process it's perfect because
these are mathematically well-defined if
you're going from one data into another
so these different geographic
coordinates then that is you're using
these different interpolation schemes
and so you can actually it can be a
little bit of loss in it you're not
necessarily gonna be as precise
generally your tooling is gonna handle
this for you but it's important to know
that that's what you're doing so then
finally you know like what do you
actually do when you're dealing with
this I mean I gave you a bunch of theory
hopefully it wasn't too boring but
really I mean I sort of think of is it's
it's the gender the fundamental steps
that you do that I find myself doing all
the time are really quite simple you
load in some data from some source maybe
you created this data or you good at
from like a survey from a satellite
imagery whatever it is you do some sort
of transformations on this and this is
sort of the key thing is that whenever
you do these transformations you
basically just want to say if you're
combining two different data sources you
need to make sure they're in the same
coordinate systems
sort of general rules of thumb is that
you know you want to transform it into a
projection that matches what kind of
calculations you want and then the other
rule of thumb is that if you're dealing
with vector data and raster data which
is very common you want to transform the
vector data to match the raster data and
the reason for this is that you know
raster data is an image if you make a
transformation on the image then you
might be splitting a pixel into multiple
pixels and that means that you might
have some irreversible processes there
it's not going to be perfect so as much
as you can you want to sort of treat the
raster data as is people who put
together raster datasets that you're
working with do a ton of work to try and
make it as accurate as possible and then
you know you just want to make the
transformation to match it and then once
you're done here once you do your
transformations then you're combining
datasets and you're making some
calculations so for example you know if
you have a polygon you you might use
that polygon to mask the raster data and
then make some calculations on that we
find ourselves doing intersections of
polygons all the time so for example you
have a field and we want to know sort of
is this field in our service territory
which we define via some polygons or you
want to know sort of what what what
government Ward it's in whether you know
Ward skate that sort of thing you
calculate areas of things I mean you
know the sky's the limit once you're in
this sort of calculation phase but this
sort of load transform and then you do
some combinations calculations is
the is the general process that you go
through and so here's the tools that I
use all the time
ultimately there's these low-level tools
that are really highly optimized and
typically the way I do it I do almost
all my calculations in Python and
there's almost a one-to-one mapping of
these highly optimized low-level tools
within a Python library that wraps
around it I think about this in terms of
the types of data structures you have so
if you vector data Shapley is the thing
that does the actual manipulations of
these objects so if you have polygons
lines points then Shapley is the thing
that does your you know you're
calculating intersections that sort of
thing
and it's sort of unaware of all the
complexities to do with projections and
all that stuff Fiona is a great way of
loading data in and out and pipe Raj is
the way you actually change your
projections on raster data really the
only the only library I use is raster IO
it kind of does all the things you need
in terms of reading it in and then any
sort of calculations using the raster
data and then you can also mentally drop
into low-level numpy and do whatever you
want sort of miscellaneous lis geo
pandas is great it basically extends
pandas to allow you to do a lot of the
geometric operations so if you can use
it I recommend it it kind of gets
complex if you dealing with large data
sets since it just reads in everything
so if you're dealing with a really large
data set you might need to be a little
bit more careful about how you read it
in but then it you know it supports all
of your normal pandas operations all
those you know very nice row oriented
calculations and also plotting stuff so
Descartes and Carter PI are the things
that I use the most they're they're
matplotlib based so you then you know
once you once you get into that realm
you can do whatever you want with with
MATLAB as well okay so that's sort of
the the background things and now I kind
of want to walk through a little bit of
an example dealing with nighttime lights
and wealth so to start out with can
anybody name this country yeah so yeah
so this is Germany right pretty easy to
tell you know you see a really nice
shape you can point out all the big
cities the urban areas
pretty pretty nice so what about this
country what was that Syria yeah yeah so
this is this is Nigeria it's a lot
harder to tell you know these areas down
here this is the coastal area around
Lagos and then you know up in the north
there's there's not nearly as much night
lights so you might think you know I'm
choosing a hard one because you know
boundaries are maybe a little bit easier
but if I show a different country can
you guys do this one yeah pretty pretty
easy all right so here's here's an
in-between one yeah Mexico that's pretty
good right okay so I love dealing with
night lights I think it's a really
fascinating data set and it's because of
this sort of interplay between night
light intensity human activity and
wealth so one of the big sources of
night light did is actually the military
militaries are super interested in this
because of its correlation to nightly
activity so this data that we get is
actually generalized over many many
images in order to remove like transient
light effects clouds things like this
but the military is really the only ones
who are collecting this kind of data
because most uses of satellite imagery
you don't really want high-resolution
night light data because there's not not
a whole lot going on there you're
collecting lots of images of oceans
things like this that aren't that
interesting but the military uses it for
things like you know are people trying
to hide activity and you know in the
desert things like this so so if you are
trying to do some covert operations do
it on a cloudy night as well as at night
so so we're gonna do those we're gonna
try and sort of look at night lights and
wealth and so concretely we're gonna
look at this demographics and Health
Survey in Nigeria which is why I was
showing you Nigeria to begin with which
is a survey that's done to collect
information about all kinds of
information but one of the things were
interested in sort of assets this is
something we're interested in at Apollo
because making calculations on night
light data is is very cheap and we want
to try and find as cheap ways as
possible in order to collect data
that's meaningful for us because we need
to do that in order to serve our
customers at scale and this work is a
little bit motivated by this paper in
science so they did some of this stuff
and it's something that we're quite
interested in following up on okay so so
to just sort of like walk through the
process of what we're doing I'm linking
this again if you guys are trying to
follow along but basically what we're
gonna do is we're gonna load in some
data so we're gonna load in this survey
data which is vector data we're gonna do
some amount of sort of poking around a
little exploratory data analysis some
plotting then we're gonna load in the
night-light data similarly we can kind
of explore it a little bit I already
showed you you know the the pay off a
little bit so unfortunately and then and
then we want to extract the night light
intensity for the areas of interest and
and then we can make some calculations
on that and then finally we can make
make some plots so this is a fairly
standard process here okay so the load
in this data I use geo pandas because I
can I can get away with it here and this
just makes my life a lot easier so you
know very simple to read in this kind of
data you know like classic classic
pandas single line load kind of thing
and then we can look at the head the
head first couple rows and so what we
see here is we see these cluster ID
because it's a survey data it's somewhat
anonymized there are I think about
80,000 rows but only about 800 clusters
so they anonymize the data a little bit
it has an asset score and then this is
what you see a lot of in pandas so this
is the geometry and so the way in which
geo pandas works is it has a special
column that does all this sort of
geospatial stuff in this case it's
nicely labeled as geometry and and
what's inside here is typically a
shapely object and so these are points
so what we have here is a series of
points that were probably collected by
somebody using their GPS and then
located for these clusters and then the
other thing we want to look at is what
is the coordinate reference system and
again not so that's so surprisingly we
see the epsp 43:26 which is why we know
it's a something like a GPS location
okay and now you know typical
exploratory data analysis so you know
because it's pandas we can just sort of
take advantage of all of the typical
pandas functionality so we can just
easily make a histogram of the asset
scores we you know we see that this is
some sort of normalized score you know
centered around zero and then what's
more interesting is then we can kind of
try and actually pay plot the spatial
distribution of this so again here what
I did as I hit a little bit of the
messiness from you in these slides if
you look in the notebook it shows
exactly I did this but using pandas type
you know grouping on clusters
aggregating you know I get this cluster
level data set and now I can plot the
point of each cluster by the mean asset
score and so we'll see here is you know
you've already seen a satellite imagery
of of Nigeria at this point and we see
that that's you know the clusters down
here tend to have a lot more a lot more
assets as we get into the north we see
you know much lower asset scores for now
what we want to do is we want to try and
combine that with the satellite imagery
data so we used raster IO to do this
again you know fairly simple you know
open command and as I said you know what
happens is this is just an image with
some metadata and so we can kind of poke
around out what the metadata are we can
look at the coordinate reference system
life is pretty easy here because our
coordinate reference system is the same
we're still in 4326
this is kind of where I say like this is
a little bit confusing because 4326 is
actually the geographic coordinate so
this is specifying you know the shape of
the earth Howard Howard how we're
measuring lat lawn and what we mean when
we say lat lawn but in this case we'll
all we've doing is we're transforming
lat lawn to XY right so there's just
this direct correlation between lat lawn
and XY and so that's why it's that's how
we're projecting it we can also sort of
look at the boundary of this image and
so this gives us a bounding box the
thing that's important to recognize that
the units here are going to match your
coordinate reference system and so the
units of the bounding box are in degrees
lat/long and so then when you look at
sort of the image size so this is a
massive image I can't even plot this
image on my computer crash
but what we do have is the ability to
use this metadata in order to do a
mapping from the pixels tool at lawn and
so we have that connection so we can do
any sort of calculation we want on the
specific area of interest you okay thank
you five minutes for Maya talk or five
minutes done there's questions time
starts yeah okay that's great okay okay
so again you know this is sort of the
simple way of masking just to look at
Nigeria so all we do is we bring in the
polygons of night of Nigeria which I
just took you know the the Geo pandas
has these sorts of things built in so
you can figure out what that polygon is
and then you mask it and so all that's
doing is it says just give me the pixels
that are inside that polygon and then I
can plot that as an image and now what
we want to do is we want to calculate
that for each cluster point and the
thing that's a little bit complicated
about this is that a cluster point it
doesn't have any intersection right it's
just a single infinitesimal point and so
you you'll get an error it'll say there
are no pixels that are encompassed by
this point and so what we want to do is
some sort of buffering operation in
order to expand that pixel to a real
polygon and so a buffer is just you know
pictorially if we have a line and we
buffer it by a distance we take all
points that are within that distance and
so that's we want to do we want to
buffer this to a P of polygons but
there's a little bit of uncertainty here
because the way the buffering operation
works is it's going to be within that
projection system so if we naively do a
buffer we're buffering in degrees lat
lon
and that's not really what we want to do
because a degree of latitude or
longitude has a different distance
across the earth so as you go to north
northern hemisphere one degree or
further polar I should say one degree of
longitude has less distance than around
the equator and so in order to do this
we do a series of transformations we
transform it into us into a coordinate
reference system that is in meters and
has a small amount of distortion in the
area we're interested in in this case I
just sort of Google around and I find
this one so this is a nice one that has
small amounts of distortion within
Nigeria and so I transform it into that
quarter
this system then I do the buffer by 5000
meters 5 kilometers as I know that
that's the amount that this has been
anonymous and now I have a polygon but
now I'm in the wrong coordinate
reference system to do my calculations
on the nightlights so what I do is I
transform it back so ultimately what I
end up with is a polygon in lat lon
that's it that is a constant 5 kilometer
circle on the earth and so sort of
pictorially if I do this in the centre
of Nigeria I get a circle that looks
like this and let lon but if I do this
in Germany I'm going to get a circle
that looks like this and lat/long but
this is actually the same size and shape
on the earth which is what I care about
and so now you know this is sort of an
in pseudocode how I do this
you know I define this this coordinate
reference system this is my old
coordinate reference system i do these
series of projections and now i do the
same thing where I basically am doing a
masking operation on the nightlights and
then I can calculate the mean value of
night lights within that polygon then I
can plot this as a you know sort of see
the relationship between mean night
lights and the median cluster assets and
we see there's a pretty clear
relationship here you know people who
have very low assets produce almost no
night like activity and then as you get
higher asset scores then you start
seeing a range and activity if you go to
the the github repository I also did
this a little bit in the US it's kind of
interesting to see because you see a
very clear like you know up and then
down you know very wealthy areas in the
US actually reduced net less nightlights
than other areas it's kind of
interesting to see that the variance so
that's that's sort of that's sort of it
I hope this is interesting
I hope you know I kind of convinced you
that working with geospatial data it's
really powerful the nice thing for us at
least and I'm sure for many other people
is is quite cheap and you know I think
it's a lot of fun to play around with
these things general guidelines just
make sure you're matching the coordinate
reference systems if when you're
comparing data you want to transform to
projections that make your calculations
easy and accurate
and then when you're dealing with the
raster data you always want to transform
your vector data to match the raster
data and then finally you know Python
really provides really excellent to only
wrote that so with that hopefully I did
well enough on the time how am I looking
perfect thanks about 40 useful an
interesting talk
so we have time for some questions any
questions raise your hand all right I
answered the more you answered a lot in
your talk obviously but one question
right digit rise thank you it was very
interesting talk I was also curious
about your user not of tools like qgs or
leaflet or other things that are maybe
more well-known to the common people
yeah it's interesting so I don't know if
everybody heard he was asking about
comparing the tooling to QGIS some of
the other tooling that's out there yeah
so in my experience I think like a lot
of those tools work great if what you're
you're after is like producing you know
producing really high quality images and
things like this if you want that kind
of thing for the type of work I do I
mean I work as a data scientist and so
we're interested in sort of trying to do
these things as programmatically as
possible and I found that like python is
a really good tool for that it also
mixes really well at the rest of our
analytic stack and any sort of
calculations we're doing leaflet is
something else you mentioned so leaflet
is a good way of doing visualizations so
if you want to try and do like you're
building an app and you want to try and
surface these insights to your customers
then then this is a good way of going
and you know there are lots of tools out
there you know including in Python to
allow you to sort of interface nicely
with that stuff as well yeah
No thank you for the talk was really
interesting I was wondering if you could
tell us how would you be how it will be
normal day for you using these tools to
solve Paulo's problems yeah so asking
about a normal day yeah so I think um
yeah so a lot of what we end up doing is
is designing we design a lot of systems
to allow us to do things in sort of like
a you know very rigorous way with it's
like things like the school location
example right so we've designed we want
to come up with a proxy for location so
we use at school location but then we
end up running with problems where
you're like great well how do we know
the school location so people like we do
a survey we ask people they like send us
an SMS or something to say whether their
closest school is but they're wrong
right and and and so now we're like okay
cool like actually that's some really
interesting insight for us like we're
trying to design a credit product we
want to know like our people who are
correct about their school more more
likely to repay like does that or is
this fraud right so we want to say okay
cool like let's let's this is a for me
as a data scientist I'm like if this is
my thesis I'm interested to know if
there's a relationship between what
people say and what's true and so now I
build this this you know I try and build
a model on this so now I'm looking at
like not just what you say but I want to
know how far off you are so I calculate
what is actually your closest school and
then I say how far off are you from then
so now I have this process of saying you
know some of these can be quite memory
intensive right to calculate the actual
closest school I have this huge database
of tens of thousands of schools I have
to go through them all and so you know
you're trying to play these sorts of
games about being efficient but then you
can come up with a plot and say like you
know what is the distribution of actual
school distance to report at school
districts distance for people who repaid
their loans versus people who defaulted
on their loans and you know you play
these sorts of games